faut arrêter avec les bébés on les
congèle on les brûle on les donne aux
chiens il est loin le temps béni où l'on
noyé le petit Grégory dans la Bologne et
basta
[Applaudissements]
bon écoute
le temps que il fasse son truc et après
tu reviens
d'accueil
et la semaine de Stéphane disons
[Applaudissements]
pour la sortie d'un guide gastronomique
Nicolas s'est fait offrir une veste de
chef soigneusement coupée à sa taille
c'est une première c'est une première
une veste de chef qui tient dans un rond
de serviette
pour l'anniversaire de Jacques Chirac
Bernadette lui offre deux nuits à
l'hôtel Meurice si c'est vraiment pour
son anniversaire elle lui laisse la
chambre et elle ne vient pas
grève à force de passer des journées
entières dans leur voiture certains
Français couchent avec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça vous tente ou pas ce genre de
la vérité j'ai peur de comprendre et là
dans le cul la bouteille ou pas non non
il y a pas de bouteilles c'est juste
tu vois des trucs qui sont pas vraiment
dans les images
[Applaudissements]
Trump passagers de clandestins découvert
dans une camionnette ils ont suivi le
conseil de Christine Lagarde privilégier
le covoiturage
en Suède les seins nus ne veulent plus
être interdit de piscine ah enfin un
combat qui vaut le coup de descendre
dans la rue
faits divers dans les Bouches-du-Rhône
le froid fait 4 morts on vous l'a dit
répéter le soir quand vous rentrez chez
vous mettez le chauffage c'est tout con
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans l'Allier trois ados jugés pour
avoir lancé un bébé faut arrêter avec
les bébés on les congèle on les brûle on
les donne aux chiens il est loin le
temps béni le petit Grégory dans la
Bologne et basta
[Applaudissements]
international la Grèce accusée de
torturer ces immigrés clandestins ici
c'est un immigré qui nous torture tous
les vendredis soirs
[Applaudissements]
c'est chiant c'est chiant pourtant on
fait tout pour le mais bon
le premier salon du divorce s'est tenu
en Autriche de nombreuses propositions
pour oublier l'être cher un aller-retour
au Tchad dans l'après-midi et également
un pari Washington avec escale bretonne
ou un pêcheur peut vous traiter d'enculé
littérature l'Encyclopédie du mauvais
goût est sorti un grand merci à Régine
qui a posé en couverture
mauvais goût toujours alors que le
pouvoir d'achat des Français s'écroule
gala sort un numéro spécial luxe exemple
Joël robuchot nous propose sa recette du
chou-fleur au caviar pour tous les
pauvres qui nous écoutent privilégiés le
chou-fleur
il y a la cinquième aussi du calvaire du
fils Belmondo qui lors du Koh-Lanta
Italie a perdu 16 kilos et ses brisés la
clavicule il n'y a pas que le Bangladesh
dans le Figaro Magazine une attaque
surprenante d’étienne Daho contre Mimie
Mathy c'est bien de grandir
à propos des peines de coeur d'Evelyne
Thomas Évelyne Thomas c'est plutôt cramé
super cramé
et on termine en beauté enfin une jolie
photo d'Emmanuel Béart la comédienne
cache ses lèvres elle s'est photoshopée
elle-même
à la semaine prochaine merci et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu